[Musique]
emmanuel macron si le jeu des 7
différences quelle différence y at il
entre le présent la république et le
candidat emmanuel macron aucune
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que ne
serait-ce qu hier soir on l'attendait à
un discours sur la coke vide 19 que tout
le monde avait besoin entendre et on a
eu un discours de campagne électorale
j'ai énoncé un certain nombre de
déplacements des ministres sur le
terrain qui pour lequel il ya un mélange
des genres qui est récurrent le matin on
est dans sa fonction de ministre et puis
bon soir même on lance la campagne de
façon tout à fait naturelle son clavier
aucune difficulté franchement ce qui se
passe c'est purement scandaleux de la
même façon j'ai compris ma question
d'actualité en énonçant le fait qu
emmanuel macron était en train d'acheter
son élection et je maintiens le principe
les milliards les millions tombent
chaque jour chaque soir et on en est
aujourd'hui en moins de trois mois à
plus de 25 milliards d'euros de dépenses
et au mépris de toutes les institutions
que ce soit le parlement que ce soit le
conseil d'état et au mépris surtout d'un
équilibre budgétaire quand on sait qu'il
est loin d'être réalisée et ça c'est
aussi un tous campagne
[Musique]